Pascal you've mentioned that you're very
visual what's your process for creating
a beautiful image it goes first it's
because when people do independent film
they don't think as does it look like
film because when you check any kind of
film there does where there's like art
director and set designer and stuff like
that because they take the time to make
sure that it looks great it looks great
on camera there's layers there's colors
that it's vivid and so I know for that
since the beginning I understand that
concept that makes sure that everything
you put the camera in is there for
reason and it looks visually stunning
and it can be visually stunning in so
many ways but at least that it looks
like film because let's say you know you
don't don't shoot in a white room in
your apartment stuff like that it's just
going to be blend it doesn't look film
looks amateur and so that's why there's
so many location mountains forests ocean
construction site whatever there's so
many plays that have layers that texture
that that looks vibrant so once you know
that theory then after that applies
everywhere so that's why but in the film
itself it was crucial to have those
location it's there for a reason for
that type of dreamy relationship that
they're having because they are in this
kind of a fakeness world and I wanted
those kind of fakeness dreamy
over-the-top romantic location and it
worked but at the same time it's it's
hard to find them you have to you know
you have to dig deep in google and
search and after that call them and ask
permission and stuff like that but again
it's I had good deals for example to
Castle they were amazing because in
general they chart a lot of money and
but because they love my work they
really gave me like an amazing deal so
again it's all about showing the work to
have stuff easier otherwise it's just
gonna be hard hey I'm a director but I
have nothing to prove to you or show you
but can I have a great deal you know so
but yeah so visual is it's important to
have this wow factor at least even Bill
Gates is if you're going to do something
that sucks make sure that it's look
amazing symbolism in your films I know
that's something that's very you said
every location there was a reason for it
yeah you talk about why that's
Orton to you ice but I love you know
French wave film and stuff you know
those French film they have a lot of
symbolism in it and that's my background
a little bit but that's something I
think sometimes people are missing they
just want a cool thing what is the cool
thing that we can put visually that
looks great but you're supposed to to
create a message they're supposed to
have a meaning beyond your story so it's
not just the character and story it's
about the music you're choosing the
lyrics of the music the tone of the film
the color you're choosing the location
you're choosing so everything needs to
be about the story the world that you're
creating and if you forget one bit or
one part of it and it's not going to
work there's just going to be some kind
of disconnection so having those a
simple yeah so having those symbolism
it's I think it's crucial to just tell
the story in a way that you don't have
to say it and I think that's that's
crucial because there's so many thing
you can say what i was saying it if you
just pay attention and i think that's
what makes fem brilliant you just watch
it again and again and again you're
going to see you the you're going to
discover thing for example the shining
from Kubrick it's just like my god it's
days and days and days of classes at the
University of just talking about so many
things Kubrick is the master of
symbolism there's ug check is shining
this everything is there for a reason
the painting the ceiling the everything
so people don't see that people don't
care at the same time when they watch it
but it's there and without knowing and
noticing it it's there and if you wash
it again you're going to say hey what
about this and what about that and it
makes the film i think brilliant so I
think it's crucial
you